this video is sponsored by afk arena
attention all phantom thieves attention
all phantom thieves
persona 5 is having a brand new
collaboration with afk arena that you
can get involved with
right now for real yes ryuji i'm being
deadly serious afk
yeah i mean i just told you it's really
happening ryuji it's real
yes it's for real ryuji
that's right afk arena have just added
two hot new characters into their roster
and with the iconic persona 5 art style
along with the fresco painting like
character designs of afk arena this is
one of the most unique collaborations
you can find
if you didn't know afk arena is a
free-to-play rpg on your mobile it's one
of the only rewarding rpgs i can play
during my busiest times thanks to its
idle mechanics you can level up and
collect resources
even if you're afk you only need to
check your team from time to time to
reap the rewards but it has enough
strategic gameplay to appeal to both
casual and serious players they've done
plenty of collaborations with other
games and anime from things like
assassin's creed
overlord and persona 5 is just the
latest in a long line of cool
collaborations
if you download right now you can try
out joker and queen for free for
three days and if you want them there
are ways to redeem the heroes for free
or you can just purchase a bundle to get
them
use code persona 5 for 500 diamonds 500
hero essence and 500k gold
and codes happy 2021 for 33 faction
scrolls
if this has caught your interest and
stolen your heart then you can click the
link in the description to download afk
today on ios and
android and with that said let's get on
with the video
i'm just gonna throw out the elephant in
room to get over with you know it
i know it 2020 was just the game of
thrones season 8 of years
somehow the scriptwriters managed to
make this an unending barrage of
nightmarish plot twists even m night
shyamalan couldn't see [ __ ] coming
while also making it feel like the most
boring filler arc of my life
but hey at least we had anime kind of
i'll be honest
i've been marathoning through as much
anime as i could for the past month
trying to catch up with the year but
even then i've watched way less than i
usually would
i don't think i have enough to talk
about the best of each respective
categories like i usually would
so instead i'm just going to revert back
to some old school youtube click bait
and do my
top anime i've seen this year before we
get to that though here's a quick
rundown of all the other things i wanted
to talk about that happened this year
studio passion started 2020 by drawing
the line between hentai and anime with
invisible
ink into species reviewers just straight
up air the hentai scene which i
constantly have to remind people
happened earlier in the year
not in 1947. a revolution was started
against mao funimation heated out faster
than you could say anichan my hips are
moving by themselves the anime community
was ablaze
and in between all this interspecies
reveals actually aired honestly despite
how many boundaries this push and how
explicit it was i really found this to
be a funny comedy that was just me and
the boys hang out in a hentai
made for degenerates by degenerates it
was just a genuinely good laugh meaning
this was one of the first ever hentai
you could watch purely
for academic purposes wait a minute
aside from the usual best girl debates
for once we have
several contenders for worst girl of the
year in one corner we have rachel from
tower of god and in the other
mommy from rent a girlfriend and i mean
what can you say about the competition
rachel was a character that felt
entitled while happily taking advantage
of the people around her to reach her
goal but
in the moments that really mattered spat
on everything she was given giving the
biggest middle finger any anime
character has given in years
and even further in the webtoons she
continues down this path
literally ruining lives and becoming one
of the most truly decrepit and vile
female characters
i've ever had the displeasure of
experiencing
but on the other hand mummy did lead
some guy on twitter decided it was now
illegal for anyone below 5'3 to possess
breasts
b star's recent success on netflix
really changed a lot of perception when
it came to 3d anime and i'm sure netflix
was sitting there like
damn we want more of this
i honestly don't know what world i'm in
where this is a real scene from ghost in
the shell and not some benny hills
looney tuning skits
but at least they're carrying on the
ghost in the shell spirit tackling deep
themes of technological existentialism
in episodes like
edgelord the revolution of the 14 year
olds
i repeat edgelord the revolution of the
14 year olds
which i assure you is an actual gitz
episode and not a rejected pewdiepie
video
i can't wait for season 2 when we get
standalone complex episode 19
virgin army revenge of the pogchamps
here's an exclusive clip i just received
now
oops japan since was an absolute [ __ ]
trip and probably the hardest i laughed
at any anime this year but probably for
the wrong
reason anime rapper eminem japan sinks
more like japan stick i honestly feel
like there was a big hole this year in
terms of anime fights normally some of
the biggest moments in the year of anime
are defined by some of its biggest
fights and this year just felt
like we didn't have too many to pick
from probably my biggest disappointment
was god of high school which somehow did
the impossible
and made me not care about the
tournament arc how the [ __ ] do you do
that god of high school
call it to poor adaptation rush pacing
bland plot or characters but this was
the one show i
really really really wanted to love
but couldn't as hard as i tried i just
couldn't get invested in it and it hurts
me showing these clips because i can't
think of another time i got to see such
beautifully animated and intense fight
sequences that i couldn't give
less a [ __ ] about watching this show
felt like watching the grown up version
of those [ __ ] stick figure fighting
flash videos i thought were the [ __ ] as
a kid i honestly feel the best way to
enjoy this anime is just to watch the
fight sequences out of context on
youtube because you'd get the same
amount of enjoyment
but yet it's still up there some of the
best fights of the year but just how
technically impressive they were
but then in that sense the best anime
fight i saw this year
wasn't even from an anime the legendary
team that worked on the naruto and
sasuke vs momoshiki fight randomly
showed up in a chinese anime and just
casually flexed on everyone by
showcasing one of the best animated
sequences in all of 2020.
starting things off with a high
intensity free running scene that
absolutely dropped my draw on the floor
it then proceeds to transition into an
insane 1v3 hand-to-hand martial arts
brawl that is absolutely dripping in
style and swagger
i mean just look how [ __ ] cool this
is you got all this fancy footwork the
absolute bravado of these exchanges and
then he has the [ __ ] audacity to just
grab his hat midair after dodging oh
god it's so cool you can tell the team
have a genuine passion for martial arts
in both real life and on film because it
doesn't seem like anyone is even close
to touching them when it comes to raw
fight choreography this wasn't just cool
for an anime fight this was just a
badass martial arts fight period the
show is hitori noshita the outcast by
the way alright
let's get down to brass taxes
[Music]
when you hear about the show that starts
off with the guy getting hit with a
truck that ends on one of my favorite
anime of the year list
i'm sure everyone's first thought is oh
great another shitty iso guy giggot
staying on brand as usual but rest
assured
tony kawa over the moon for you is the
furthest thing you'd expect
me to like a short sweet cute wholesome
story about a simple domestic
romance wait in the modern times of
anime titties dominating your timeline
anime and hint are designing as one and
the same and the world's being taken
over with degeneracy it's refreshing to
finally see a nice christian anime with
nice christian values
tony kawa is the rehabilitation needed
for all of those who have once been put
into horny jail
so all of us there's no complicated
dramas no love triangles no
relationships that need to be prefaced
that they're not related by blood
just the story of an actual decent
responsible human being
falling in love with one of the few
waifus in anime that um
is actually a waifu watching tony kawa
is like taking that bath after a long
day at work
you feel like your soul is cleansed
whenever you finish an episode it'll
cure your depression and give it right
back to you when you remember that
you'll never get a relationship like
this
what'd you say anyway watch tony kawa
it's cue
yeah kaguya summer is still good
ever since my last video about index and
railgun over two years ago your boy's
been pretty quiet about the franchise
as a whole and well that's because when
jc staff adapts an anime
god flips a coin would it land heads
like for the corner super movie or would
it land tails like for one punch man 2
the [ __ ] of index 3 or the
underwhelming accelerator damn that's a
lot of tails but for some
unknown reason science still hasn't been
able to solve whenever they touch
anything related to railgun it is
nothing but
heads heads and heads railgun somehow
continues to be far and beyond the best
thing the franchise has going for it
when it comes to the anime which kinda
makes sense
with the index series having a far
greater plot juggling a bigger cast
squeezing way more story arcs into a
single season it's no wonder that the
more focused world of railgun means the
spin-off series outshines the main line
and
well it seems like jc staff knew this
too because unlike their other recent
adaptations this is the best the
franchise has looked since
well railgun the great animation is back
we have a more down-to-earth story it's
got
all the level fives going at it this is
everything tawaru fans could hope for
not forgetting it's nice to see the
return of everyone's favorite character
cgi wind turbines baby oh
[Music]
i always feel a bit cheap for putting a
hot new shonen on the top of my
favorites list because to me it kind of
feels like i'm saying yes
i too enjoy vanilla ice cream eating
white bread and saying rem is my waifu
but my god when a show is doing
something right
it is doing something right watching
this first call of jujitsu kaisen kind
of felt like he discovered that youtube
channel under 10
000 subscribers that you knew was just
waiting to blow up
it's a shonen that isn't afraid to wear
its influence on its sleeves but is
confident enough in its own abilities to
still give you a fresh experience
and it does you can see the groundwork
being laid for a truly amazing show
because it just seems to have
everything going for it the characters
are fresh and likeable the fights have a
nice balance between interesting power
systems and just pure animation flexing
gojo's eyes make me question my
sexuality as much as a stolfo's dick and
it has an ending that slaps harder than
my dad's belt
i feel like he's just waiting for that
one big moment that one big fight to
truly take it up to the big leagues
because with demon slayer coming back
this year from
literally kicking everyone's ass jesus
[ __ ] christ 54 million
the sales gap could part the red sea i
can't wait to see if jiu-jitsu kaisen is
also going to be eating at the big voice
table in time like
what is it now big three big five big
seven
how many more are you going to give us
shonen jump
this year the domestic girlfriend mark
ended and it left a massive hole in my
heart
where was i going to get my fix of a car
crash field romance story now
how could anything fill the gap this
masterpiece had left
would i finally get some good taste in
anime
luckily rent a girlfriend started airing
and it all went tumbling down again
this unironically became the show i was
most excited to catch up to every
week yes [ __ ] you i was more excited for
this romance than kaguya what can i say
you can take the man out of the trash
but you can't take the trash out of the
man it's another romance anime that
follows the formula by the book but
sometimes you just find a show that
contains every stupid eye rolling cliche
you've ever complained about but
somehow it balances them all in a way
that just works i don't know what it is
about seeing people going through a
train wreck of a romance situation
that's just so addicting to watch
you know what i did i went on grindr and
dude i was a hit on grindr by the way
i was a hit on grindr almost instantly
but then i literally saw my dad rent a
girlfriend was just that perfect kind of
a train wreck
it may not be highbrow entertainment but
it knows how to keep you watching you
may be infuriated watching this living
breath moment in action you may be
screaming at the screen for him to leave
his hoe on the streets
you may want to buy this guy a [ __ ]
pint for just telling it how it is but
by god you just gotta click on the next
episode for this morbid curiosity just
to see
how many more elves a single man can
take
jesus christ
hello yes i like to report a [ __ ]
murder
also when was the last time we had clear
candidates for both best and worst girl
of the year in one show i've already
talked enough about the waifu
masterpiece of this chizuru but i'm
equally impressed at how good a job they
did at creating the most detestable
serpent of a human in mommy everything
she does makes me want to drop a c-bomb
so hard i'd get an honorary citizenship
to australia
and it hurts me that for some reason i
still see people who think mommy is
alright and i
genuinely don't know if they're just
trolling or if i've just interacted with
a psychopath like come on guys you're
joking you gotta be joking right there's
no way you're not joking they say a good
salesman can sell ice to eskimos and
here rent a girlfriend is casually
selling trash to
garbagemen
[Music]
i have this really strange addiction on
youtube about watching videos on
subjects i have
absolutely no knowledge in because
beyond finding content centered around
my hobbies
i find it fascinating watching
passionate people present their
interests
because sometimes a bit of that passion
can rub off onto you
there's just something magical about
watching people do the things they love
and this is exactly how i felt
watching keep your hands off as again
masaki iwasa essentially just made a 12
episode personal love letter to
animation and you can
feel that passion bleed through every
single frame of this show
azakin was so strongly imbued with such
an overwhelming excitement for the art
form that it was infectious
even if he had zero interest in it you
don't need to have ever tried making an
anime because anyone who's worked on
something creative i'm sure has a little
bit of all three of the girls fighting
inside you whenever you work on a new
project the one who thinks up wild ideas
you may or may not actually be able to
do the one who wants the project to be
perfect and won't settle for anything
less and the one who has resting breath
face
the constant struggle of having a vision
you want to be realized versus the
practicality of achieving it in a
reasonable time frame while also not
forgetting the economics of labor was
something i deeply related to but what
really shines through
is yuasa's pure love for animation
there's this episode where one of the
girls sees her grandma throwing tea
and something about the way it looked
fascinates her
she does it again and again over and
over cleaning up and throwing more tea
trying to recreate every little detail
every little movement until eventually
this random childhood story would be
translated into an animation cut that
would appear in their anime for
less than a second yet somehow this one
little meaningless cut conveyed a sense
of personal love that struck a deep
chord with me if there was something
magical about the art of animation
yuasa definitely showcased it here
[Music]
[Applause]
after 2019's adaptation of attack on
title and finland saga watching great
pretender made me wonder if studio witch
should be reported for aimbotting
because right now
these [ __ ] just don't miss the
heist genre is something we don't
normally see in anime aside from lupon
iii
and well that's about it but i am not
overstating it when i say great
pretender is the greatest
highest anime since lupon iii
only big statements here following a
group of professional swindlers who are
like the modern day robin hoods except
they steal from the rich and give
to themselves this felt like a truly
triple a anime production
the unique genres the gorgeous color
palettes and allowing me to officially
say that freddie mercury is in an anime
ost but most of all it was refreshing to
have an anime that truly felt
international not only did we get a
wider range of settings globally from la
london
shanghai france singapore and tokyo
hustling drugs hustling gambling
hustling world famous paintings from
painters everyone's heard about
but the worldwide feeling was reflected
in the characters themselves
way more attention to detail was given
to the characters speaking different
languages and how fluent they should
actually sound as opposed to most other
shows where it just felt like they just
got a random guy off the streets
native voice actors were used to dub not
only characters in their respective
countries but also the main cast too
it really looks like they used this
medium to its full advantage to make it
feel like these were truly well traveled
multilingual characters which can often
be a challenge to pull off in movies
they call him samurai
he speaks fluent japanese what does
katana mean
it means japanese sword i was actually
going to put this as my anime of the
year until
the last two episodes happened alright
this is going to be my only chance so i
really need to rant about this ending so
if you don't want to be spoiled skip to
the time stamp here because
i really need to get this off my chest
all right
everyone good okay so i know this is
meant to be a fun show not to be taken
too seriously but this ending took my
suspension of disbelief stretched it to
bloody narnia and then shot into the
[ __ ] stratosphere so somehow they
built an entire building in the middle
of nowhere and none of the marks didn't
question the fact that they randomly
passed out and sometimes woke up in a
completely different vehicle dorothy was
alive all this time and now all their
old targets
we've spent episodes building up to be
[ __ ] detestable [ __ ] bags are now all
helping them and our buddy buddy
like how the hell did they pull that off
yeah so i know we stole 100 million
dollars for you and completely ruined
your life but uh want to help us out on
this job well what's in it for me
we'll put you on a boat where you can
reminisce about the time you got scammed
by us
well even though you're a group of con
men who've lied and backstabbed me
before
i see absolutely no reason i can't trust
you but worse than that
worse than all that is they already had
both targets drugged
unconscious with their money in hand
which essentially made
everything they did here [ __ ]
pointless
like i get there needed to be some kind
of payback scheme other than just taking
the money and running but you're telling
me they couldn't have thought of
something a little simpler than
contracting an entire skyscraper to be
built on a remote island and putting on
a [ __ ] soap opera broadway show
just so the marks can play cast away for
a few days just [ __ ] kick one of them
in the balls or something man and be
done with it
jesus these guys are playing 5d
interdimensional chess using a ruby
goldberg machine when all they needed to
do was walk a ball into a [ __ ] open
goal [ __ ] it there run done
i don't know what it is about a lot of
anime that netflix licenses but
if i had to put it into words they don't
feel like you're eating a mcdonald's
chicken nugget
dora hedorah just felt so insanely
different from anything else i watched
this year
if most anime was like taking a stroll
down a bright city center dodo hedorah
was the homeless bum trying to stab you
when you took the wrong turn in the back
alley it wasn't cutesy it wasn't squeaky
clean it was a brutal psychedelic tour
through anime's underbelly and it was
awesome there's something so fascinating
about being dropped into a world that
doesn't follow any logic you're familiar
with and yet seems to function in a way
that makes sense under the foundation it
was constructed in
the world of dora hedorah feels
absolutely alien there are sorceress
that can do magic because they have dust
in her body our main character has a
lizard head and another head inside his
head this man can turn everything around
him into mushrooms and then decorate to
smoke them we even got
gargrida preparing for her hololive
debut yet somehow all this makes sense
under the insane logic of its own world
seeing the universe function under its
own twisted sense of coherency just made
me want to learn more about it
every episode was just a treat to see a
new side of this world operate
it was unflinchingly brutal yet didn't
feel out of place when you saw a nine
foot talking cockroach wearing air
jordans coal would jordan
almost kill a granddad because they're
doing a june mayada baseball episode
this is one of the most unique
experiences you can find in 2020 and all
i can say is
season 2 better be around the corner
because 12 episodes was not nearly
enough to contain the insanity that is
dodogedodo
sometimes when a massively hyped
high-profile sequel comes along years
after the original aired
after a myriad of memes discourse
merchandise parodies and spin-offs have
warped your perception
it can be easy to forget why the
franchise became so beloved in the first
place but all it took was a few minutes
of the first episode iv
instantly remembered god damn i [ __ ]
missed re zero it's a great feeling when
a season two
instantly lives up to the hype but
what's even better is when it takes
those foundations and builds it into
something greater
you weren't dying you got more dying you
thought death scenes would become
mundane just because subaru got used to
them
let me introduce you to the monty python
rabbit oh
you liked amelia boom amelia 2.
oh you liked rem
[Laughter]
[Music]
rem two but what surprised me was just
how much better we ended up
understanding subaru he was no longer
just an isekai protagonist he was no
longer just a deconstruction of an
easter kai protagonist he was a
relatable
surprisingly self-aware lad thrown head
first into a situation
way out of his depth out of every show
on this list
it was the only one that really gave me
moments i felt i was going to remember
those moments in anime that hit that
perfect crescendo and leave you in a
state of shock
or amazement or sometimes tears
these are the moments that remind me why
i [ __ ] love anime and somehow it felt
like re-zero was able to do this on a
weekly basis
because those moments were the big
feeling i feel was missing from the
anime this year
i've had to add one big asterisk to this
is that it feels weird crowning this as
my anime of the year
because well it isn't even finished yet
it's not like attack on titan season 3
part 1 because unlike something like
that we are right in the middle of a
story arc but
i had to pick it because i didn't feel
like i had
any other choice alright let's be real
for a second last year i said that
picking the anime of the year was the
hardest in a very long time but
honestly this year was almost equally as
hard
for the completely opposite reason you
may notice this year i'm not doing one
of my coveted anime in 2020 yearly
reviews and that's because to me those
videos always felt like a celebration
that puts a personal full stop on my
year of anime but
this year it just wasn't something i
felt like celebrating
obviously i don't think anyone feels
like celebrating the year of 2020 in
general but i also genuinely think that
anime as a whole
just wasn't very exciting this year
don't get me wrong there were good shows
and i enjoyed every anime on this list
but it felt weird calling any of these a
proper anime of the year contender
some were unfinished or felt more like a
setup season some dropped the ball
crossing the finish line and some were
missing that x factor to truly leave a
special impression because whenever i
reflect on a year
i think back to the moment and aside
from re-zero
there were hardly any moments this year
that reminded me why i love
being an anime fan compared to last year
when we had the demon slay episode that
broke the internet
villain saga's ending mob psycho's jaw
dropping fights seven page muda isabel
song stone age light bulb or pretty much
every moment from attack on titan i
don't know what moments in this year i'm
even going to remember and i don't feel
like i'm alone in this
being an anime fan was weird this year
because it seemed like there was the
least discussion and hype for the medium
that i can remember for a long time
but that doesn't mean we were talking
about nothing because
if i were to crown my actual anime of
the year
would probably be this
nothing beats a ground pound
please don't try to drink my chicken
2020 may not have had a single anime
stamp its mark on the year but when we
look back we are going to remember this
year as the rise of b
tubers and yeah i know this is a
complete cop-out because this ain't an
anime but let's be honest
this is what a lot of us anime fans
ended up watching and it would feel
wrong to admit them when reflecting back
of this year for us weebs
in a time when the entire world had more
free time to consume content than ever
before a time when new anime just wasn't
up to par
a time that couldn't be more perfect for
every anime fan to finally make a dent
in their god forsaken plan to watch this
did we do it now let's watch a bunch of
anime girls saying
[ __ ] the bottomless pit that was the v
tube of rabbit hole came along and
swallowed us all into its endless abyss
pitting us in the battle of the century
on one hand you had a lifetime of
careful financial decisions and proper
money managements drilled into us over
years of common sense
versus some virtual pixels reciting 1
26th of an alphabet
guys it wasn't even close and i think
what this really cemented was the birth
of a proper subculture within the anime
fandom
youtubers gacha games manga readers web
and light novel readers i know a lot of
people who call themselves
anime fans who kept up closely with the
culture while
hardly watching any anime i think the
best way i can put this is that this was
the year where being a weeb was
something distinguishable from being an
anime fan because while every weeb might
be or has been an
anime fan not every anime fan is a weeb
yet 2020 may go down as one of the worst
years in history but
thank god for the virtual anime
characters that made our days
a little less depressing the future is
bright
the future is hopeful the future
is cute anime
girls and boys and i wouldn't have it
any other way
[Applause]
hey guys happy late new year and hope
you enjoyed the video
thank you again to afk arena for
sponsoring me today if you want to give
their persona 5 collaboration a go then
just click the link in the description
to download it today
and also thank you very much to elephant
basil
mike elfin payne patchett walter
and everyone else my patreon for helping
to support me for this month
so like i said in my last video i've
been working to try and get ahead and
work so i can actually have a schedule
and well so far so good i'll be aiming
for a minimum of two videos a month with
some extras here and there
not a huge increase i know but uh it's
better than the one video a month i was
doing for the previous months before
this
right now you can expect my winter
seasonal video to come at the end of the
month
so um yeah we'll see how long the
schedule can last
i can't wait to eat my words at the end
of this year
for this month anyway that's it from me
for today
i've been giggup and i will see you all
next time